monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le vice président de l'assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
mission de la mémoire de l'esclavagé des
traites et de leurs abolitions
mais c'est le premier ministre hier jean
marc ayrault mesdames et messieurs les
députés sénateurs
monsieur le représentant de la
présidente la région madame la
représentante de la maire de paris
mesdames messieurs les élus
monsieur le président du comité national
pour la mémoire et l'histoire de
l'esclavagé cher frédéric régent
monsieur le préfet mesdames messieurs
les ambassadeurs
messieurs les autorités religieuses
mesdames messieurs chers nadia mourad
prix nobel de la paix 2010 8 chers
élèves depuis 2006 le 10 mai la journée
nationale des mémoires de l'esclavagé
des traites et de leurs abolitions
la loi l'a voulu jacques chirac l'a fait
et c'est la première fois que je
m'exprime devant vous à cette occasion
je le fais car je mesure ce que
l'esclavagé la traite les abolitions et
leur héritage représente dans l'histoire
de notre pays dans notre culture dans
notre âme
cette histoire et notre histoire
elle a donné à la france un destin
mondial elle a forgé les combats et les
valeurs de la république
elle explique que la diversité de notre
société
elle nous relie à l'afrique aux caraïbes
à l'amérique à l'océan indien
la loi qui porte votre nom cher
christiane taubira a reconnu la part
tragique de cette histoire et grâce à
vous la france a été le premier pays
dans le monde à reconnaître avec autant
d'honnêteté que la traite et l'esclavagé
constitue un crime contre l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce que la représentation nationale
a reconnu à l'unanimité il y a dix huit
ans telle était la vérité et il fallait
qu'elle fut dit
mais l'histoire a continué cet ordre
injuste et barbare a été contestée
d'abord par les esclaves eux mêmes qui
n'ont jamais cessé de vouloir devenir
libres qui ont toujours résisté à leur
servitude que ce soit en se forgeant une
culture et une spiritualité propre par
laquelle il affirmait cette humanité qu
on leur nier en prenant la fuite
les armes la plume en se révoltant et
partout en europe à travers tout le 18è
et le 19è siècle des philanthropes et
des intellectuels se sont aussi battus
contre la traite et l'esclavagé au nom
de l'humanité
certains de ces résistants des colonies
et de ces libéraux de l'hexagone repose
aujourd'hui au panthéon
oui sont honorées parce que leur combat
cet engagement ont fait deux de grands
hommes
l'abbé grégoire condorcet toussaint
louverture louis delgres s victor
schoelcher ces combats jalonnent notre
histoire jalonnent l'histoire de la
république des révoltés de saint
domingue appelant les révolutionnaires
de paris à abolir l'esclavagé en 1794 à
cyrille bissette le martiniquais luttant
pour l'émancipation sous la monarchie de
juillet aux côtés de lamartine de
schoelcher oui entre la scea l'histoire
terrible de la servitude à laquelle des
millions et des millions d'êtres humains
ont été réduits pendant des siècles il
yal'histoire sublime héroïque édifiante
de tous ceux qui ont secoué et briser
ses chaînes odieuse
face à l'horreur de l' esclavage il eu
l'honneur de la résistance et le bonheur
enfin de l'émancipation
c'est une histoire française
une histoire universelle
cent soixante et onze ans ont passé
depuis l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans
les colonies françaises
mais les conséquences de ce passé sont
là toujours là car son héritage
aujourd'hui c'est la géographie de la
france contemporaine son identité
d'archipel mondiale qui va de l'europe
aux antilles de la guyane aux
mascareignes
c'est le français que l'on parle sur
tous les continents avec sa richesse et
sa variété
ce sont aussi des idées nouvelles des
rencontres inattendues des imaginaires
inédit la négritude d'aimé césaire et de
léopold sédar senghor le syncrétisme de
jean michel basquiat la littérature
puissante de maryse condé 7 hier et
aujourd'hui
là bas comme ici le métissage des
cultures la créolisation du monde
c'est tout cela la mémoire de l
esclavage et c'est tout cela comporte et
les militants
les artistes les citoyens les élus qui
depuis les années 1990 se sont battus
pour que cette mémoire soit mieux connu
mieux reconnus mieux comprise mieux
partagée aussi je veux leur rendre
hommage aujourd'hui sans eux sans les
artisans de la marche du 23 mai 1998
sans les mots de christiane taubira sans
les livres d'edouard glissant et de
patrick chamoiseau cents l'action des
élus locaux
pionnier de cette mémoire comme vous
cher jean-marc ayrault
sans le travail des chercheurs des
historiens comme vous frédéric régent
jamais la loi du 21 mai 2001 aurait été
votée jamais eu 10 mai puis le 23 mai
n'aurait été
institué en journée nationale toutes et
tous ils nous ont rappelé cette histoire
non pas pour nous diviser ou nous
opposer mais pour nous rappeler ce que
nous sommes une nation de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité de diversité
c'est aussi pour cela que la mémoire de
l'esclavagé ne doit pas seulement être
convoqué l'ours lors de ces deux
journées nationales et n'être évoqué que
dans des discours annuel
elle a besoin d'actes de lieux
d'institutions de travail ce sont les
engagements concrets que j'ai pris le 27
avril 2018
à l'occasion du cent soixante dixième
anniversaire de la signature par le
gouvernement provisoire de la république
du décret d'abolition de l'esclavagé
dans les colonies françaises
d'abord érigé à paris dans le jardin des
tuileries un mémorial qui rendent
hommage aux victimes de l' esclavage
ce monument sera situé au coeur de la
géographie de cette histoire entre
l'ancienne demeure royale et impériale
des tuileries
là où la convention qui vota la première
abolition tenez ces séances et l'hôtel
de la marine
là où a été préparée la deuxième
abolition
cette part de notre histoire enfin
s'incarnera dans un lieu évident
significatif solennel où nous pourrons
nous rassembler pour l'évoquer ce
mémorial sera inaugurée en 2021 et je
souhaite que ce moment soit pour notre
pays l'occasion de rendre aux victimes
de l'esclavagé à leurs descendants et à
leur apport inestimable
l'hommage solennel de la nation qu'il
mérite en y associant toutes les
composantes de la société française
la fondation pour la mémoire de
l'esclavagé sera l installer dans les
tout prochains mois à l'hôtel de la
marine
je veux saluer le travail que vous avez
accompli
cher jean marc ayrault pour en préparer
la création dans le prolongement des
rapports d'edouard glissant et de lionel
zinsou
vous avez su rassembler un large cercle
de partenaires publics et privés de
collectivités de l'outre-mer et de
l'hexagone de personnalités réunies dans
le comité de soutien dont christiane
taubira a accepté d'être la présidente
et je l'en remercie
elle apportera la fondation son verbe sa
force son aura
tous ont adhéré au projet que vous leur
avez proposé celui d'une institution
nationale moderne rassembleuse en prise
avec les outre-mer est ouverte sur
l'international
cette fondation sera un partenaire
incontournable pour l'état et la société
civile pour les enseignants et pour les
chercheurs pour les collectivités
territoriales et les institutions
culturelles et patrimoniales pour les
artistes pour les médias surtout elle
sera au service d'une grande ambition
renforcer la cohésion nationale en
transmettant l'histoire mondiale de la
france
en célébrant les cultures qui en sont
issus en promouvant les valeurs
républicaines d'émancipation ici et dans
le monde
j'ai souhaité également que le musée qui
dans notre pays est consacrée à cette
histoire et à la promotion des
expressions culturelles qu'elle a
suscitée que ce musée soit renforcée
dans son statut comme dans ses moyens
ce musée c'est le mémorial acte de
pointe à pitre en guadeloupe
je sais combien les présidents la
délégation de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat tenait aussi à ce que
l'ensemble des territoires de france
puissent porter cette mémoire le
mémorial acte deviendra ainsi un
interlocuteur capital pour les
institutions homologues en europe dans
la caraïbe l'afrique et les deux
amériques
il lui fallait pour assumer cette
vocation une assise plus large et plus
solides
c'est pour cela que l'état a décidé de
soutenir le mémorial acte en participant
à sa transformation en établissement
public de coopération culturelle
autonome ce nouveau statut permet
d'associer à sa gouvernance la région le
département la ville de pointe à pitre
la communauté d'agglomération et l'état
la région qui a engagé ce projet à
l'initiative de victorin lurel
et qu'ils continuent de le porter avec
énergie aujourd'hui à travers la
détermination d'un riche à lui en
restera le principal soutien
mais l'état prendra toute sa part nous
nous y sommes engagés
enfin parce qu'elles racontent les
racines des valeurs républicaines parce
qu'elle rend compte de la diversité de
notre nation parce qu'elle libère aussi
d enfermement communautaire cette
histoire doit être transmise à la
jeunesse de france
je veux ici remercier l'ensemble des
élèves ici présents mais à travers vous
tous ceux qui sont représentées qui se
sont engagés auprès de leurs maîtres et
grâce à l'engagement aussi des
professeurs ici présents à faire ce
travail
[Applaudissements]
c'est évidemment se souvenir c'est
comprendre notre histoire c'est en
déplier toute la complexité mais c'est
aussi le donner à vivre au présent en
montrant comme vous l'avez fait ce que
cela dit de notre citoyenneté et en
montrant que ce qui peut être une
évidence ou parfois pour le pire en
redevenir une a été défait par des
combats menés par la république et est
pour ce qui est de l'égalité de la
fraternité le fruit de conquête
véritable les programmes scolaires
aujourd'hui le permettent l'histoire de
l'esclavagé désormais le sujet du
premier chapitre des programmes
d'histoire de 4e et dans le cadre de la
réforme des programmes du lycée les
élèves de 2de traiteront de façon
approfondie du système esclavagiste de
sa naissance
au xvème siècle à son paroxysme au
xviiie siècle les programmes de première
étudieront le long combat des abolitions
jusqu'au décret de 1848 un monument au
coeur de paris un musée au rayonnement
renforcée des programmes scolaires
renouveler une fondation à vocation
internationale installée voilà mesdames
et messieurs ce dont la république
française se dote pour porter et
transmettre cette mémoire mais nous ne
saurions rester là car l' esclavage
comme vous venez de le rappeler monsieur
le président du sénat n'appartient
malheureusement pas qu'à notre passé et
la république ne serait pas la
république si elle ne mener aussi ses
combats partout dans le monde qui sont
ceux de ses valeurs de ses principes
oui l' esclavage demeure une terrible
réalité contemporaine vécue par plus de
20 millions de personnes des femmes et
des enfants en grande majorité ils se
déploient aujourd'hui partout partout là
où
en afrique en asie au proche et
moyen-orient le temps long de l'histoire
à enraciner ces pratiques infâmes
partout où les conflits sont revenus
s'installant sur les haines ethniques ou
religieuses partout où l'organisation du
monde s'est progressivement installée à
nouveau dans des formes d'exploitation
de l'homme par l'homme
alors face au travail forcé à l'
esclavage domestique à l'exploitation
sexuelle à tous les abus à toutes les
formes contemporaines d'esclavagé
c'est un devoir d'action qui est le
nôtre c'est à cette fin que la france
lutte contre la traite des êtres humains
dans les zones de conflit alors que
vocaux à ramer dahesh sont intégrés
cette pratique alors funeste stratégie
de terreur c'est pour cela que nous
soutenons l'initiative de daniel book de
nadia mourad et denis mukwege et prix
nobel de la paix 2010 8 de créer un
fonds de réparation pour les femmes
victimes de violences sexuelles dans les
conflits
et pour cela hr nadia que je vous
remercie de votre présence ici parmi
nous vous êtes l'incarnation même du
fait que ces combats ne sont pas
terminés avec courage vous avez survécu
à ceux des shows qui voulez vous tuer
avec courage vous avez affronté ce que
votre famille a subi les crimes les
viols l'éloignement l' esclavage avec
courage vous vous battez pour que ceux
qui existent dans la région encore
aujourd'hui soit définitivement
éradiquée c'est à dire toutes ses formes
d' esclavage qui continue à tenter à
notre dignité à nous aussi
c'est pourquoi votre combat cher nadia
est aussi le nôtre
[Applaudissements]
c'est aussi pour cela que le premier
prix simone veil de la république
française a été remis le 8 mars dernier
à la camerounaise à ciadoux marc a
engagé de longue date contre l'
esclavage sexuel
ces combats en afrique en asie au proche
et moyen-orient
ce sont toujours des luttes pour
restaurer notre dignité pour poursuivre
ce combat auquel nous venons aujourd'hui
de rendre hommage et de nous souvenir
c'est le sens même de notre action au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies ou
dans le cadre de notre présidence du g7
de lutter contre les trafics de migrants
contre les trafics d'êtres humains qui
aujourd'hui continue de sévir dans le
sahel en libye dans la corne de
l'afrique et qui chaque jour installe
l'exploitation des êtres humains comme
une règle comme un moyen de vivre pour
les organisations terroristes
internationales
et comme une honte pour nous tous c'est
pour cela que la france poursuivra au
sein de l'organisation internationale du
travail la lutte contre toutes les
formes d' esclavage par le travail de
travail subit de travail sous payés et
d'exploitation les textes sont là la
convention des nations unies contre la
criminalité transnationale organisée
dite convention de palerme est là elle
doit encore être ratifié par de nombreux
états et nous nous battrons pour ce
faire depuis octobre 2018 et l'adoption
à l'unanimité par les nations unies
d'une résolution portée par la france
avec l'italie et le costa rica un
mécanisme d'examen de l'application de
cette convention de palerme est en
oeuvre et nous poursuivrons ce combat
sans relâche et le 20 mai la france
rejoindra la campagne core bleus des
nations unies qui précisément a pour
objectif d'encourager les états comme
les citoyens à se mobiliser pour lutter
contre la traite
des êtres humains notre combat en europe
dans le multilatéralisme contemporain se
poursuivra pour que partout où les
formes d'esclavagé contemporain existent
elles soient combattues et éradiquer et
pour que dans tous ces pays où ces
pratiques sont subis d'autres enfants
puissent comme vous l'avez fait
aujourd'hui racontés dénoncer ce que le
combat de quelques-uns aura permis
d'effacer
nous n'oublions ainsi ni la mémoire des
victimes de l'esclavagé ni celle des
héros qui l'ont combattu
nous n'oublions pas surtout ce message
qu'il ya plus de deux siècles la france
a lancé au monde tous les hommes
naissent libres et égaux en droits un
message dont nous devons aux esclaves
révoltés de saint domingue d'avoir
révélé la portée véritable et qui est
devenu l'étendard de toutes les
abolitions c'est ce message que nous
continuons de porter aujourd'hui en
donnant à cette mémoire des lieux où
elle peut s'inscrire en créant des
institutions où elle peut être transmise
en combattant toutes les formes d'
esclavage qui persistent dans le monde
et en soutenant les héros de notre temps
qui luttent pour les émancipations et
les abolitions qu'il reste à conquérir
il s'agit simplement d'être fidèle à
notre devise de garder la force
contemporaine de cet esprit de
résistance qui nous a fait d'être fidèle
à notre république à ce que la france
incarne à ce que nous sommes
merci à vous vive la république
et vive la france